tomás dejo dos paquetes para enviar un
paquete peso 1.38 kilogramos y el otro
paquete peso 720 gramos cuál es el peso
combinado de ambos paquetes en gramos
así que el primer peso no los dan en
kilogramos y el otro peso no nos dan en
gramos cuál es el peso combinado de
ambos paquetes en gramos lo que tenemos
que hacer aquí es tener ambos pesos en
gramos para después sumarlos y tener el
peso combinado vemos que el peso del
segundo paquete ya está en gramos pesa
720 gramos así que tenemos que convertir
el peso del primer paquete de kilogramos
a gramos así que queremos conocer cuánto
es 1.38 kilogramos que podemos abreviar
así y nos dicen que un kilogramo es
igual a 1000 gramos y esto es lo que
significa este prefijo de kilo mil así
que para pasar de 1 a 1.38 pues tenemos
que multiplicar esto por 1.38 así que
en este lado de los gramos vamos a tomar
esta cantidad y también la vamos a
multiplicar por 1 punto 38 así que
tenemos 1000 x 1.38 va a ser igual a mil
380 gramos que abre veamos así ahora
vamos a sumar el peso de ambos paquetes
este es el peso del primer paquete en
gramos y vamos a sumarle el peso del
segundo paquete 720 gramos lo sumamos 0
+0 08 + 12 10 llevo una 7 más 13 10 más
una que llevo es 11 uno más uno es 2 y
nos queda que el peso total es de 2.100
gramos hagamos otro problema de
conversión de unidades
julia y sus amigos están haciendo
papalotes de papel para cada papalote se
necesita un pedazo de papel que tiene
puntos 65 metros de ancho cuántos
centímetros de papel se necesitan para
hacer 4 papalotes aquí nos están
diciendo el ancho del papel en metros
pero quieren la respuesta en centímetros
es la respuesta para 4 papalotes
pensemos en esto cada papalote mide 0.65
metros así que para pasar de 1.65 pues
multiplico esto por punto 65 y ahora del
lado de los centímetros
voy a multiplicar estos 100 centímetros
también por punto 65 y así obtendré la
cantidad en centímetros del ancho del
papel de cada papalote bueno 65 centenas
por cien va a ser igual a 65 centímetros
y esto es para cada uno de los papalotes
así que el ancho de un papalote en
centímetros es 65 centímetros pero no
nos están preguntando cuál es la medida
en centímetros para hacer un papalote
sino que nos preguntan los centímetros
de papel que se necesitan para hacer 4
papalotes así que vamos a multiplicar
esto por 4 4 por 5 es 20 llevo 24 por 6
6 20
42 26 nos quedan 260 centímetros es la
cantidad necesaria de papel para hacer 4
papalotes hagamos otro problema más
omar vierte 5 litros de agua en dos
peceras derrama 200 mililitros de agua y
después divide el agua restante por
igual entre las dos peceras
mililitros de agua vertió omar en cada
una de las peceras así que queremos
nuestra respuesta final en mililitros
así que vamos a convertir la cantidad
original en mililitros
comenzamos con 5 litros de agua cuantos
mililitros serán nos dicen que un litro
es igual a mil mililitros así que si
tenemos cinco litros multiplicamos
nuestra cantidad por cinco así que esto
será igual a cinco veces esta cantidad
de mililitros mil por cinco es igual a
cinco mil mililitros con esto comenzamos
pero antes de que omar divida el agua en
dos peceras derrama 200 mililitros así
que a esta cantidad le quitamos 200
mililitros y nos queda 4 mil 800
mililitros
y esto es lo que se va a dividir entre
las dos peceras y nos preguntan cuántos
mililitros de agua advirtió omar en cada
una de las peceras así que si esto se
vierte en dos peceras pues cada pecera
tendrá la mitad de esta cantidad cual es
la mitad de 4800 pues es igual a 2.400
mililitros
esto es lo que omar va a vertir en cada
una de las peceras